[Music]
in the previous videos we've seen how
the oboe library makes it easy to play
low latency audio but what if you need
to record audio in this video I'll show
you how to setup low latency streams for
recording recording audio is done in
much the same way as playing audio the
main difference is that our audio stream
moves data from an audio device for
example the built-in microphone rather
than sending data to it before creating
an input audio stream you'll need to
make sure that your app has acquired the
record audio permission to create the
input audio stream we use an audio
stream builder settings stream direction
to input and the performance mode to low
latency now we can open the stream by
passing a reference to an audio stream
pointer after checking that it opened
successfully you can start the stream
data from the default recording device
will start moving into the stream there
are two ways we can read this data
either directly or using a callback it's
possible to obtain the lowest latency
using both approaches I'll demonstrate
how to read directly from the stream
since the callback method was covered in
the previous video the method we need is
unsurprisingly called read it takes
three parameters buffer is an array into
which the audio data will be read num
frames is the number of audio frames to
read and timeout nanoseconds is the
maximum number of nanoseconds which the
method will block for if you specify 0
here the method will return immediately
copying only the data that was currently
available in the streams buffer this is
useful if you don't want to block the
current thread so let's say we wanted to
read 2 milliseconds of audio data from a
16-bit mono audio stream we can do this
using a blocking read start by creating
an array to store the frames of audio
the amount of data we need to store will
depend on the stream sample rate the
timeout should be longer than the amount
of audio we want to read in this case
we'll use 3 milliseconds and convert it
to nanoseconds
incidentally ogo provides a number of
for constants for working with different
time units before we can read from our
stream we need to clear out any stale
data which might already be in the
streams buffer to do this we just
perform non-blocking reads of the whole
buffer until it's empty now when we've
read from the stream we know we're
reading the most current audio data
after Reed is completed we need to check
the result if it was okay then result
that value will contain the number of
frames which were copied into our buffer
to read more data surround this block in
a while loop this approach allows us to
process small buffers of up-to-date
audio data for processing and moving
elsewhere after we're done we must close
the stream and after a stream has been
closed it can no longer be accessed this
is a very simple example of how to
record audio for more complex examples
including how to implement synchronous
recording and playback check out the
live effects sample on get up you can
also check out the other videos in this
series the first video is an
introduction to oboe shows by low
latency audio is important and the
second video shows you how to create low
latency audio streams for playing sound
that's all for now if you have any
questions issues or feature requests
please post them in the issue section of
the oboe github site we'd really love to
hear from you good luck and go make some
noise
[Music]
you